Donald Trump has made one of his boldest
false claims yet he's insisting he can
overrule state governors who have issued
stay-at-home orders the US president is
in hyper defense mode after intensified
reporting which says he repeatedly
failed to absorb the extent of the
corona virus pandemic everything we did
was right if we would have closed down
its long away here you think everything
you did was right well look governor
should have had ventilators they chose
not to have them we were able to get on
ventilators you haven't heard other than
you know there was a lot of panic a lot
of scream will you one ventilator they
got the ventilators Trump is trying to
rewrite the narrative of his response in
the latest briefing he came armed with
this propaganda like video concerned
about the corona virus because they're
hearing a lot of news about it right now
it did not include his comparisons to
the common flu nor his claims that
Americans were at low risk all made when
the stark warnings were out there in the
briefing room at least the video did not
have the desired effect when he was
repeatedly pushed about the timeline of
his response you bought yourself some
time you didn't use to prepare hospitals
you didn't use it to ramp up testing
yourself useful so disgraceful the way
you said it you know you're a fake you
know that your whole network the way you
cover it is fake one of his top medical
advisors dr. Anthony Fouts she walked
back comments he had made conceding that
lives could have been saved if social
distancing had been started earlier so
it was a poor choice of words there
wasn't anybody saying no you shouldn't
do that everything I do was voluntarily
please don't even imply that these
briefings have become a platform for
Trump's worst instincts with the main
focus on how he's being viewed in the
media when the country he leads has more
deaths from coronavirus than anywhere
else in the world Amanda Walker Sky News
Washington